your man matthew what's going on i'm
madly in love with him the kardashians
new hulu reality show will you be tuning
in um i won't be tuning in
oh you came to celebrity big brother to
win and it just became like eighth grade
on the playground and i was just getting
like bullied
by a vote
of four
to zero
shayna
you are evicted from the big brother
house
shayna mokler freshly evicted from the
celebrity big brother house
what the heck happened you know i don't
know
i think you know it was really
challenging in there playing with some
players because um you know i'm a super
fan uh of the show and there were just
some players in there that i've never
played and i just don't think they
really understood what was going on 90
of the time you know my head is still
just like sort of like blown from the
from the whole last like you know 48
hours of things but i know you shayna
you're a fierce competitor i know you
came to celebrity big brother to win
uh are there any feelings of like
disappointment bitterness i'm definitely
frustrated and um you know i knew
when i was playing the game and i made
that power move you know that i was
really you know drawing a line in the
sand and i knew how todrick and misha
played so i was you know i told cynthia
and carson like hey now that we have the
power now that we flip the house i know
they're gonna come for me you know
please come and talk to me please come
and like if anything is said and i just
feel like i never was given that chance
you know and then it just became like
eighth grade on the playground and i was
just getting like bullied and drew a
line in the sand and i i i pulled you
off the block and you're gonna send me
home it just was like i couldn't wrap my
brain around it i still can't
when you exited the celebrity big
brother house yes you had that one
little final message for daddrick don't
worry todrick i'll get the jury to vote
against you
that's fine
don't be too hard on me now i will i
will never vote for todrick
i will never ever ever vote he will
never get my jury vote so you can all
know america
whoever is sitting next to dodrick will
be getting my vote over him who do you
feel the most betrayed by oh carson for
sure i mean i you know taking him off
the block i not only you know saved him
i saved cynthia as well but even maybe i
mean cynthia i just don't feel like
understands the game whatsoever or what
she was even doing in the house i think
she was definitely riding the coattails
of carson but carson definitely you know
like i've done a tv show with him before
and i at least thought he would at least
give me the
common courtesy of having a conversation
with me um they wouldn't even talk to me
that's what was so mind-blowing like i
was like no one will talk to me do you
feel like you're owed an apology
um i think that would be appropriate i
didn't even get the opportunity to play
in a veto and save myself and i would
never have done that to them that's like
a really dirty thing to do in this game
so looking back on this whole celebrity
big brother experience any regrets
yes keeping carson on the block taking
carson off the block
and although i hadn't done that he would
have went home i still would have had
chris kirkpatrick in the house and
cynthia probably would have been next
and then possibly depending on hohs and
vetos could have picked off you know
todd and lamar and went head to head
with misha and todrick so that's
definitely a regret but you know i took
my shot i swang and i missed no i mean i
don't know if you've checked social
media shayna but everybody you haven't
checked social media no i have not
oh my gosh the fans are riled up on
another level everybody is demanding
that you're voted america's favorite i
mean what is that support and that
reaction oh my god to you know to hear
that is very um
makes me want to cry because uh
i need that support after that
experience so but that i mean that's
really cool to hear that people
understand you know how i felt and uh
definitely feels nice
you said that you know you think you
know some people in the house just
really had no idea what they were doing
and yeah you as a super fan i believe
you've said you've watched every season
you know everything about big brother
yeah is there a chance that we could see
shayna mookler on
regular big brother like do you want to
be thrown into the trenches with the the
real deal players i mean that would be
very exciting and fun or if you know
they ever had an all-star or something i
think would be really fun to do
now we got to see you and your pal lamar
odom really bond in the house you even
made a joke about a comment you made
about his ex-wife you know 10 years ago
on yeah not my final moment
i went to do the wendy williams show
she just asked me like oh are you going
to attend
lamar and chloe's wedding i thought she
said kim
and i didn't like him right right and
i was like i'm not gonna go to that
donkey's wedding no
but the thing is is like i didn't even
know chloe did you and lamar have a
chance to like talk about that and and
your kardashian connection um i never
told him about the comment heard all
around the world on the wendy williams
show
um it was not one of my proudest or
finest moments i'd like to pretend it
never happened so if he didn't mention
it i wasn't mentioning it however you
know he did share you know how he still
you know cares very deeply for chloe and
i thought those sentiments were like
very sweet and you know and he does know
that my ex-husband is now engaged to a
kardashian as well so we did have that
that sort of connection um but you know
yeah he was he was just a nice person
and um and he was he was a blast to play
with yeah i think a lot of people
expected commentary from you uh about
your ex and his new fiance but we didn't
see that i mean what do you have to say
about that um i think people
you know because of things that have
happened in the press or comments that i
have made people think i'm um really
obsessed with the relationship or i'm
bitter or i'm jealous and i'm just not
you know i'm in a relationship and i'm
really happy and
you know it's just not something that is
centered in my world when you stood up
on the show and you kind of like said
your final piece
one of the people you shouted out was
your man matthew you're so excited to
reunite yes matthew i cannot wait to
kiss your face tonight on valentine's
day what's going on have you been able
to talk to him have you been able to see
him yes yeah um he was the first person
i saw when i came home and it was so
amazing to see him you know being in
that house that was one of the things
that got me through those those long
days and nights was you know the moment
i get to see him again reunite with him
look i like to go to you
before anybody else you know there are
reports that you've unfollowed each
other and that there's some some drama
going on can you set the record straight
um sure right now um
i haven't been on social media i have
had someone uh running my social media
for me so i don't know what's going on
there but um right now um everything is
good and we're working on things and
we're in a good space and we're just
gonna move forward
and see where things take us
okay so you and matthew you're on you're
still together things are good at the
moment yes okay good you know when i
spoke with you about a year ago um you
and matthew i think we're sort of newly
dating so are we exchanging the l word
are you guys living together yes we
definitely use the l word i think the
institution of marriage is absolutely
beautiful and you know if it was the
right fit i would absolutely love to um
you know do that again i would i would
walk down that aisle again for sure i
think it would be beautiful a year later
how do you feel about that um i still i
still feel the same way um you know i'm
madly in love with him and he makes me
so happy
and you know if that's something
down the road he would ever want that's
something i definitely want i believe in
marriage and i think you know um no
matter what's happened in your past i
don't think you should ever be afraid to
fall in love again so um you know i
definitely uh believe in believe in that
that would be amazing you know he and i
we met and went right into quarantine
and sort of lived like a married couple
right away you know and you know that
has definitely brought its challenges
but i think we've overcome them and um
you know and he's my best friend
ati lando bama i love you so much what's
going on with your kids have you spoken
with them how do they feel about this
whole experience they've uh video called
me and just you know said that they were
really proud and things like that but um
i haven't got a full chance to uh um
i've only been out for a day so i just
needed a moment to like decompress but
yeah they you know they wrote me and
said that they were proud of me and so i
can't wait to have a sunday sauce with
them and do pasta night and just
reconnect and laugh about it but it was
definitely you know times in the house
where i was like i hope they're watching
and i hope they're proud of me and then
but just going back again to our
conversation last year you know i was
like is there a chance that your your
kids could pop up maybe on the
kardashians new hulu reality show if my
kids wanted to participate i'm all for
it fast forward a year it definitely
seems like they've been there when the
cameras have been there what do you
think about them being part of this
process and and will you be tuning in um
i won't be tuning in however
um you know i think it's fine if you
know this is an opportunity that they
want to be a part of and you know my
main concern is always you know my my
children are my first priority and you
know that's one thing that you know
travis and i you know do agree on it's
probably the only thing we agree on but
you know our children come first and
their happiness and as long as you know
the kardashians are good to my kids you
know that's all that matters to me as a
mom you know as long as they're happy
and then you know that's that's the key
[Music]